olha se este carro é da prova que
deveria 11 em rio largo às vezes o meu
tema freaking com este ano 10 facto
celso morbach sanguiné de sydney em
português da rádio fm frame sala itaú
power glove quebra é o salvar
por exemplo o professor é só vamos
tratar a falar em português sem qualquer
ainda quer eu é quase nunca falar o
português
agora você pode falar comigo não vai
falar por muito tempo
então vamos falar da questão da auto
motivação é uma um facto muito muito
importante no aprendizado de idiomas e é
em estocolmo sobre três perguntas é
muito muito muito importantes e só a voz
é é a seguinte se o seguinte vou fazê lo
ei você pode entrar quando quando o que
conquistei mas é muito importante que é
a pessoa que a gente é a certeza que
você tem certeza que possa fazê lo sem
posto de polícia
a meta é falar com é é qualquer coisa
que você vai fazer fazer um viagem se
você não acredita acredito que se você
não acreditar num poder atingir o fim da
viagem uma surpresa sim eu acredito que
cada pessoa tem a possibilidade de
tornar se uma pessoa quer pode falar
fluentemente na outra dilma com certezas
como vencer é a primeira questão a
primeira questão é a resposta é sim
6 em até segunda é perguntar vai
funcionar vai funcionar vai funcionar o
método que nós estamos utilizando
aprender o idioma será que vai funcionar
é isso é essa questão chave no chalé
então são sister distintas estradas
decisão é a maneira certa de aprender os
métodos dos anjos já esteja o importante
é você precisa acreditar num momento o
que você está usando com certeza é isso
que é importante porque é é é possível
que eu vou preferir um certo como é o
projeto 10 anos até josé pré outro herói
mas é muito importante é eu acredito no
método que estão usando assim se você
usa um método que é você quem é não
gosta ou não gosta no acantonamento não
acredita muito difícil se motivar
temos responsavelmente para isso é muito
importante então sem dúvida quem eu como
é digo sempre acredito muito é a escutar
ele é muito importante nos dias com os
jogos sem passar ontem outras
a outra cela a unidos do programa de
milhas
o importante é que você seja
compreensivo e confiante confiantes e
método dá certo com certeza é isso
a terceira pergunta é vale a pena ou não
é quando eu a tenho só a todas a bem os
benefícios que eu não obteve dada
aprendizado odeiam mas o deputado está o
profissional por toda a história em
relação ao oficial amigos
pode ser a mulher pode ser qualquer
coisa a gente e não só isso é e
conhecimento de de culturas e e eu
estaria muito grande também a feitura
aprender também se uma cultura que mas
se você não acredite a acreditar que a
obra tenha a pena eu não fazia não fazer
valer a pena o esforço seja a dedicação
com certeza é exatamente em tal como
está muito 10 amor não é é português não
então as três perguntas chaves são bons
em fazer ó vai funcionar
o valor é não vale a pena ou não ou não
ea resposta é sempre assim sei se vocês
se você puder sei pode pode ser você
pode apostar
sim as três perguntas voz já está motivá
lo no bom caminho no bom caminho para
até s tom e aprendizado de línguas
afegãs grande sucesso como zé é um como
eu acho que é muito importante
especialmente acho que pensar que vale a
pena realmente assim dizer um novo
idioma todas anos perto profissional
social em todos os aspectos das nossas
vidas não vale a pena muito e eu também
acho que você pode pensar na cultura é
uma coisa muito válida
é eu sei que me apaixona pela concluindo
aprendendo uma nova língua e da cultura
relacionada com aquela língua é uma
coisa fantástica
a terceira pergunta talvez seja minha
favorita vale a pena sim sim vale a pena
passar a questão mais importante
com certeza que é nós vamos a continuar
a criar um avião sobre o tema da
província de aprendizado de línguas
porque é você que fala não sei
quantas e quantas gramas já 10 eu diria
que sim para ter uma boca uma
conversando boa o suficiente 9 ou 10 não
vê desde seguem mais humano comum
então se isso acontecer a nossa presença
é essas conversas
sim é muito obrigado por a 0
alguém bateu o até logo